دعى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق ايهود
اولمرت الى وقف الحرب على غزه فورا قائلا
انه لا يمكن تحقيق الاهداف التي حددها
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو وقال اولمرت
في مقال بصحيفه هارتس بعنوان اوقف الحرب
مقابل عوده المخطوفين احياء قال ان مزاعم
نتنياهو واركان حكومته بانه يمكن القضاء
على حركه حماس عبر عمليات عسكريه غير
واقعيه و شدد اولمرت على ان نتنياهو نفسه
لا يصدق ان بالامكان تحقيق هذا الهدف
مشيرا الى ان نتنياهو يتصرف كممثل
استعراضي وان كل ما يعنيه هو الافلات من
تبعات المسؤوليه عن الفشل في منع حدوث
هجوم حماس في السابع من اكتوبر واضاف
اولمرت ان نتنياهو مدفوع باعتبارات سياسيه
داخليه وانه يدرك انه لا توجد اي امكانيه
لتحقيق هدف القضاء على حركه حماس لكنه منذ
اللحظه الاولى لم يكن مشغولا بالحرب على
غزه بل بحرب البقاء الشخصيه الخاصه به
وشدد اولمرت على ان اسرائيل امام خيارين
لا ثالث لهما اما ان توافق على وقف اطلاق
نار وتعيد اسرها لدى حماس عبر صفقه تبادل
او ان تواصل القتال بحيث تنتهي الحرب من
دون ان تحقق هدف القضاء على حماس ومن دون
استعاده
الاسرى الله